les gens que tu vois les gens que tu
fréquentes tu deviens comme eux au bout
d'un moment si tu es avec des gens bien
tu deviens quelqu'un de bien si tu es
avec des tordus des gens bizarres tu
deviens comme eux toi et moi maintenant
on est la somme de toutes les personnes
qu'on a rencontré dans notre vie
match le vendredi mais tu le joues pas
et ton entraîneur sil l'apprend ça
va tu as trop longtemps vécu avec ta
mère tu as laissé tout faire voilà le
résultat quand je perds je me dégoûte et
quand je gagne et je me dégoûte aussi il
y aura autre chose aussi il y aura mieux
que de l'argent mie que de
l'argent ils ont fait une autopsie Mor
naturelle c'est clair quand même c'est
clair la mort c'est clair vous allez
continuer encore maintenant là quand
vous êtes face à
face ça m'est jamais arrivé de ma
vie
moi je veux une grande